hi my name is cole de golier i'm a phd
candidate in the immunology graduate
program at the university of colorado on
chutes medical campus i'm in the
laboratory of dr terry fry
and i'm going to talk to you today about
how rational modifications to the car
antigen binding domain can improve
sensitivity to low density target
antigens
so chimeric antigen receptor or car t
cells as most of you probably know are a
very effective therapy for leukemias and
hematologic malignancies in general
on the left here
you can see that in this trial and
others that cars have a seventy to
ninety percent rate of remission
induction when used to treat v-lineage
leukemias
so in a
anti-cd22 car trial led by terry at the
nci
found that patients that relapsed often
still had c22 positive leukemia
and so
this is in contrast to what had been
seen
in previous trials targeting
such as those targeting the cd19 antigen
where relapses were cd19 negative so
this trial they saw that patients
relapse with cd22 positive leukemia
and on the right here you can see that
relapsed patients commonly had lower c22
surface expression as compared to
pre-treatment levels
and so this really led to the hypothesis
that
these cars need a high level of surface
antigen expression
in order to be fully effective and
this particularly against the cd22
target engine
so our lab wanted to
study this phenomenon and so we've
generated a number of leukemia cell
lines derivatives from the num 6 human
leukemia and we've knocked out the cd22
target antigen and then reintroduced it
at lower than wild type levels surface
density levels
and so on the left here you can see that
in the top
of this figure
when car t cells are used to treat
noun 6 leukemia on the right
they clear leukemia
fairly well in prolonged survival even
at this
lower dose however when they're used to
treat 22 low leukemia
they're not as effective in clearing
their leukemia so in addition to this in
vivo study in vitro studies have been
done that show
that cars have a number of functional
deficits when
you when stimulated by low antigen
density including a lower il-2
production
so our lab has studied this
thoroughly with the c-22 target antigen
found on
hematologic malignancies
however what's emerging in the field and
what's been seen
is that other hematologic antigens such
as cd20 and cd19
are also cars targeting these antigens
are also affected by antigen density
in addition
antigens found on solid tumors such as
anaplastic lymphoma kinase or alk on
neuroblastoma or egfr v3
cars targeting these antigens have also
been found to be affected by antigen
density
and so this lack of engine sensitivity
is a broad phenomenon of car t cells
across target engines and a major area
for improvement in the car t cell field
so we wanted to go back and look at what
parts of the car could be
modified in order to enhance this
response to low antigen density
tumors so in order to really analyze the
structure of the car uh we have to
observe the receptor which it is uh
designed uh to somewhat emulate which is
the endogenous t cell antigen receptor
or tcr
so in contrast to the tcr which
recognizes peptide antigens presented on
tumor cells in the context of mhc
molecules the car redirects t cell
specificity using an antigen binding
domain that's commonly derived from an
antibody variable region which is at the
top of the car and then
this is connected to intracellular
signaling moieties which commonly
include the co-stimulatory domain such
as cd 28 or 41vb as well as the cd3 data
chain from the tcr complex
so some straightforward modifications
have been made to
the car that can have effects on antigen
sensitivity or carb performance and
these include the co-stimulatory domain
and so swapping this out
has been shown to make a difference
as well as the number of immunoreceptor
tyrosine based activation motifs or
itams in the cd3 zeta chain which are
represented in red
however recently our lab and others have
made the observation that portions of
the car construct previously thought to
be almost inert can have large impacts
on car biology
and one of these is the flexible linker
amino acid linker region between the
heavy and light chain in the antigen
binding domain of the car
and so a group at penn made the
observation
and published recently that their car
didn't perform as well in patients as
the c22 car from the trial at the nci
and found that astonishingly one of the
only differences was
in fact the flexible linker domain that
i just showed you
and so
they
wanted to study why this was the case
and so they found that they made a car
with a short linker and these linkers
flexible amino acid linkers commonly
have been constructed from motifs that
consist of four glycine residues
followed by a serine so a short linker
is just one of these motifs and while
their long linker car
had four of these motifs in between the
heavy and light chain of the antibody
and they found that
when they
compared short and long linker cars one
of the major differences was the uh
the long
linker cars were not are able to
permit heavy and light chain pairing on
an individual car
receptor whereas uh g4s by one short
linker does not permit heavy and light
chain pairing and instead favors pairing
of heavy and light chains from distinct
cars which causes antigen-independent
dimerization
and so in the figure on the left here
they show the fluorescent microscopy
that
the shortening of the linker length
induces car clustering
and antigen independent signaling
as compared to the long linker car which
is more homogeneously distributed
throughout the cell
however they also found that when they
compared these two cars that this
antigen independent clustering induced
signaling as well
and tonic signaling of multiple
tcr signaling
pathways including ps3 kinase map kinase
and p53
so
we hypothesized based on the trial
by don terry's child that another
important factor with this short linker
car was not only the ability to do these
things but that this
would enhance the ability to respond to
lower antigen densities seen in
patients treated with c22 car t cells
and so we hypothesized that this would
require that this target engine in
particular requires enhanced and
insensitivity
so we wanted to test these our
short and long linker car t cells
against our range of
leukemias bearing different engine
densities and we found that
in contrast to the short linker car
which
was in the clinical trial when we made a
long linker uh car
that shortening the the short linker car
improved sensitivity to low density
target engines
and so especially when you look at the
cars targeting cd22 low leukemia
you can see that the short linker car
has significantly higher numbers of
cells making
il2 and interferon gamma in response to
a low antigen density stimulation
however as nic 22 cars utilizing scfcs
derived from the m971 antibody clone
bearing these short and long leakers
have already been evaluated in the
clinic we sought to assess how other
modifications to the antigen binding
domain could affect car t cell function
and whether combining these
modifications could further enhance
cartiso responses to low density
antigens
our hypothesis
is that affinity maturation of the car
antigen binding domain will enhance
responses to 22 low leukemia and this
will increase overall therapeutic
efficacy of cars targeting the c22
antigen
so in order to
in order to develop a car with a high
affinity car
our collaborators affinity matured the
m971 binder and this resulted in an scfv
with approximately one thousand fold
higher affinity for cd22 and you can see
this on the left the standard affinity
on the top the high affinity on the
bottom
the
high affinity binder
has approximately a thousand-fold
difference in the
dissociation constant kd
we also wanted a simple cell-based
readout to ensure that when we developed
these binders into
a car into the receptor and transduced t
cells that we would see a similar change
in affinity so we transduced cars into t
cells with either the high affinity or
the standard affinity binder and
incubated these cells with a range of
concentrations of a 404 conjugated c22
protein fc
and in this assay we can see enhanced
car binding of c22
with the high affinity binder
as indicated by the red trace and as
compared to the blue trace and this is
indicated by increased mfi
at lower concentrations of target
antigen indicating that the higher
affinity binder
shows enhanced carb binding
so we went on to test this in vitro and
in contrast to our hypothesis
we found that affinity maturation does
not enhance carbocytokine production in
response to low density target antigens
and in fact when you
compare the top row here the high
affinity car across antigen densities to
the standard affinity car
we found that in general the high
affinity car had lower number of cells
lower numbers of cells making
either il2 or interferon gamma in
contrast to the standard affinity car
we wanted to go on and test this a
little bit further and so we looked at a
signaling a different signaling
molecules that are known to be important
in t cell function
so
again we found that affinity maturation
does not increase the percentage of cars
that phosphorylate essential t-cell
signaling proteins phosphorylation of
the
extracellular signal-related kinases orc
one and two in particular have been
previously identified through silac
analyses in our lab as highly
correlative with car t-cell in vivo
activity
so when we looked at phospho-erc on the
top we found that across antigen
densities there were
fewer high affinity car t cells
phosphorylating earth
as compared to the standard affinity car
we also looked at several other
signaling moieties known to be important
for t cell function
and
these include nf kappa b plc gamma and
p38 map kinase and again we saw that
there really was no difference in these
signaling moieties between the high
affinity and standard affinity car
so then we took these cars
and wanted to do in vivo testing against
our 22 low leukemia and in contrast to
the in vitro data we found that the
affinity matured car enhanced in vivo
responses to
cd2 to low leukemia
so on the left is
uh
radio or radiance data or bioluminescent
imaging data comparing the standard
affinity and high affinity cars
with
luciferase labeled leukemia and we found
that the high affinity card
significantly
increased
early leukemic clearance compared to the
standard affinity cart
and this also manifested in the
increased survival of mice that were
treated with high affinity cars as
compared to standard affinity cars
as you can see on the right
so what i didn't mention was that this
high affinity scfv was sent to us
containing a g4s by 3 linker sequence
which is as i mentioned a longer linker
that does not permit card dimerization
on the cell surface
so after
understanding the biology of this
response further uh we had pos and
seeing this promising in vivo data with
the
high affinity long linker car we then
hypothesized that combining
modifications to the car antigen binding
domain
in particular this affinity maturation
and
shortening of the linker length would
have synergistic effects on car
sensitivity to low density target
antigens
however what we found was that when we
combine these modifications these two
discrete modifications of the engine
binding domain are independent in
boosting in vitro car responses to cd22
low leukemia
so we tested the high affinity long
linker on the top the high affinity
short linker in the middle and
standard affinity short linker on the
bottom
and while we saw
that
in this donor the high affinity longer
actually recruited more cells into the
activated pool producing il2 or infrared
gamma compared to the standard affinity
short linker the high affinity short
linker car performed
worse than both
other cars in this assay
we also looked again at phospho erc and
again found no significant difference
between the three cars in number of
cells phosphorylating earth against 22
low leukemia
however
we obviously wanted to test this car
again in vivo and
see if it improved leukemia clearance
in xenograft models
and what we found
was that although the
high affinity short linker car perhaps
performed slightly
worse in vivo that the
regardless of linker length the high
affinity cards performed very similarly
to each other in vivo and both high
affinity cars outperformed the standard
affinity car in clearance of cd22 low
leukemia and so this can be seen again
by
bioluminescent imaging data
on the left
in that these two cars
both have very similar leukemic early
leukemia clearance relative to
mice treated either with mock t cells or
standard affinity car t cells
and we also looked at survival of these
myosins found that both high affinity
cars significantly increased survival
relative to the standard affinity car
and that both the high affinity cars
were very similar
in their increase of survival
so in conclusion
affinity maturation of the engine
binding domain does not significantly
enhance in vitro car responses to cd22
low leukemia
however when we
tested the affinity matured car
in vivo we found that the affinity
matured high affinity car
outperformed the standard affinity car
in clearance of c22 low leukemia
when we combined the
modifications to the antigen binding
domain
including shortening the linker and
increasing affinity of the binding
domain we found that these discrete
modifications that individually enhance
car function are not always synergistic
in their
increase
in
car functions against low antigen
density leukemia
and so further study of methods to
enhance car efficacy
in the context of low density engines is
warranted
and we have manufactured and are into
testing other cars with short linkers
and this includes one targeting the
aml-associated antigen cd33
however
in order to further test this phenomenon
i've generated a
or using a genetic mouse model to study
in vivo responses of car t cells and
particularly the immune biology
in response to low density target
antigens
so this system consists of three parts
we have a murine b lineage leukemia
b lineage acute lymphoblastic leukemia
or bal
and this is on the same genetic
background as our immunocompetent mice
and
marine car t cells from
a again
genetically identical donor and so these
can be
both
cingenic or adoptively transferred into
a
syngenetic host
and
we can study the immune biology of car
responses to
to leukemia in this host other
advantages though include
that we can control both the host
environment and the president's in the
presence of endogenous target antigen as
well as different donor t cell intrinsic
factors
using the multitude of transgenic mice
that are available to do so
additionally
in the xenograft models
xenogenic jbhd can be observed and is
commonly observed at late time points
in these models
so this model allows for the transfer of
t cells and leukemia into a genetically
identical host this system extends our
ability to study t cell persistence
to much longer time points and
persistence has been shown to be a very
important factor in car t cell responses
in patients
so what we've found in preliminary
studies in this
model system is that
in
as
we see in the human system that low
target engine density also impairs the
function of marine car t cells
so as i've said we've generated a number
of
leukemia cell lines of
which express different
antigen densities by
knocking out the c19 target antigen
and reintroducing it at lower than wild
type levels
and so we can study the
responses of cars targeting these
different cell lines
and when we look at in vitro inner found
gamma production
we see that the myriad car t cells very
similar to human cars are affected
and the number of cells capable of
producing inner frown gamma in response
to low antigen density stimulation
and we very much look forward to using
this model system to further interrogate
the in vivo biology of car t cells
responding to low density target engines
so i would like to thank
the lab roots organizers for having me
today i would also like to thank the
frey lab particularly terry
as well as that walsh a previous member
of the lab who generated some of the
data i showed you today
i'd like to thank the kohler lab
particularly eric for his help and input
on this project
as well as terry's funding sources thank
you very much